hello everybody markiplier here here to
tell you that the charity livestream was
an outrageous success we did incredible
work in case you weren't there I hope
you were there was about 600 people
there at the maximum I believe and
almost 600 towards the end and we hit
two thousand one hundred and seventy two
dollars and 20 cents I believe is the
actual total that I got from chippin
that they told me what we got
so that exceeded our goal and we did
that in 11 hours and 30 minutes
that's insane for us to do that I I was
worried there for a second I wasn't
worried I believed in you guys but yeah
it was down to the wire the last just
that less a little bit there everyone
just started donating like crazy and it
was awesome we got three hundred dollars
in like 30 minutes or something insane
like that so thank you guys so much
you've done incredible work donating to
this charity and helping out for a good
cause so thank you
more than anything all I did was play a
video game and I had the time of my life
it makes me wish I wasn't in school so
that I could do more live streams not
just charity live stream but just live
streams in general because I have fun
talking to you guys and playing for you
guys and you know just having me and
wade in there around with Bob
popping in whenever you can and it's
just fun to do it's something that I
want to do more of because I don't often
get that direct connection with you guys
most of you guys who know me on YouTube
always get me like a couple hours behind
or a day behind you know whenever I
record these videos so it's not
instantaneous and it's something that I
want more but this made me realize that
it's everything that I've been saying
maybe I've been trying to talk out my
ass or something about us building the
community but this kind of ingrained it
in my mind that it's a reality now I'm
it's not a goal anymore that I'm working
towards it's happening right now we are
doing this right now
like together we're already something
and we just hit 12,000 subscribers also
I forgot to mention that yeah 12,000
subscribers we were 11,000 like just a
few days ago so it's absolutely insane
and I have nothing but thanks for
everything that you've been doing to
help out and man it's just great
you see how quickly this is growing I'm
trying to keep up with it and trying to
keep up with you guys I'm trying to keep
up with all the messages I'm actually
getting behind for the first time in my
youtube career I'm getting behind on
messages on facebook on YouTube so I am
trying to get to them I'm very busy
these days but I'm trying to answer
everyone's messages I'm getting about
maybe 50 a day so please bear with me as
I'm I I don't just write one word
answers I write well thought out and I
always read your post so I'm trying to
get you and if I haven't I will in a
second the live stream has been just
exploding messages more than ever I
think I got a hundred and past and
throughout Facebook Twitter and YouTube
and email people been sending me emails
so I've been trying to keep up
everything this but I will get to it
eventually so but anyway that's just
status update on what we have and one
more thing if you weren't in the live
stream and if you haven't noticed for
some strange reason I released a new
reaction compilation featuring the video
from slender they're all my playthroughs
a slender you know Elementary hospice
sanatorium and mansion and the original
slender and slender eight pages the new
version of the original sender so please
go see it there's a link up here there
somewhere I don't know where I'm gonna
put probably both both took both of the
links ding ding ding ding ding ding
click both the link to either one and go
there and I don't ask for it often
because I feel like it I I don't wanna I
don't want to make like it a regular
thing so that it's not important these
and these reaction compilations are
important because they take me a long
time to work I think I worked about 8
hours on this last one just straight
trying to get it to work trying to get
the words right there's got to be a
better process I must be doing in the
hard way but finding eclipse editing
down rendering and uploaded it was um a
lot of work so if you could help me out
and help to keep the momentum of this
channel going if you could go that video
and share it on Facebook and Twitter or
anywhere you can that would be of great
help because the only way that this
channel and channels like this gaming
channels grow is through word of mouth
I've mentioned this on the live stream
and thank you all who have shared
already but it would a the rate at which
we have been growing
because you guys like my content enough
that you already shared so it's
absolutely incredible knowing that
you've got my back like that and I
almost feel like I don't need to ask
anything for this and I probably won't
even ask ever again just for another
until I get another reaction compilation
out but if you could to help me out on
that that will keep the momentum going
and that way in a month or so when we do
our next charity livestream we're gonna
have double the people probably more
than double the people we're gonna raise
double the amount you know I'm probably
gonna put a four thousand dollar goal
I'm not even getting it I believe that
we can do it I believe that we can do it
because I believe in you guys and I hope
you believe in me I would even if I
could only do 12 hours 12 hours I would
still play until we reached our goal so
if I had to get no sleep and then walk
into school like a zombie I would be I
would do it and I would do it with a
smile on my face because I absolutely
love doing this for you guys but anyway
I've been rambling on much longer than I
thought I was going to do you know how I
can do that so thank you all so much for
everything you've done you guys did it
not me I didn't do jack besides play
game and dick around for 12 hours and
have fun yeah I hope you enjoyed it too
I want to do more livestream than the
future one more thing I want your
opinion glasses on or glasses off
glasses on or glasses off I got a lot of
interesting email saying that I should
bring the glasses back how do you new
people don't know that I when I started
I was wearing glasses old things so give
me your opinion glasses on or glasses
off right below in the comments so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
but I